[Music]
do you guys want to see something really
cool okay
the other day i was looking for a wig in
the storage closet here at 30 rock and
i stumbled upon something really
interesting okay
it's a journal but not just any journal
this belonged to morty swanson
the morty swanson many of you may not
know this but
morty swanson was this genius comedy
writer who used to work for nbc back in
the 50s
his pictures were said to be the most
groundbreaking
side splitting bits that anyone had ever
heard but here's the crazy part
he went missing in the halls of 30 rock
and as the legend goes
one day he went to lunch at the
commissary and was never heard from
again
which is why i can't believe i just so
happened to find his book of pictures
we gotta check it out
amber beware what the hell
you speak of that which you do not know
those pitches do not belong to you
oh my god morty swanson is that you
it is i the ghost of morty swanson
let this be your warning do not steal
those pitches
though they could make you a comedy
legend i wasn't gonna steal them i swear
i just wanted to give you the credit you
deserve you've been warned
beware
creepy maybe i should just put this book
back where i found it
but i don't know i just feel this
compulsion to keep reading
what's the worst that could happen let's
just read one okay
the fart machine 2000 this is a bit
where we imagine what farts might sound
like in the year 2000
all types of wacky farts we can really
go nuts with it
some of those are just first drafts yeah
that one felt kind of phoned in
i was still workshopping it when i
choked on that piece of hot dog
wait that's how you died well no i i
survived that but the whole thing really
distracted me from working on this pitch
and
you know it was due the next day and i i
was just really in my head
oh okay but beware
every other pitch in that journal will
tickle your mind
and tempt your soul but remember
those bits belong to another i know
i didn't mean any harm choose
wisely
maybe it's best i just throw this thing
away but then again
i have this nagging curiosity one more
couldn't hurt
the three dunces this would be a
recurring bit where we have three dunces
named
gary perry and bo they're totally dumb
and crazy and always doing dumb stuff
really physical comedy etc well
how do you feel about that one um
it's okay isn't that basically just the
three stooges though
what no why why would you say that i
mean gary perry and bo
it just seemed a little derivative and
that's
not what you're looking for i'm not
looking for anything i just wanted to
give you the credit you deserve
no no yeah totally totally um are you
going to read another one
do you want me to read another one no i
don't want any of this it's excruciating
to watch my best material being stolen
before my very eyes your best material
oh well what else is in there okay let's
see
um president truman the boob man
topical butt pooperson an original
character
this one just says die commie that
counted as a joke back then
look i gotta say i don't know if any of
these are working for me
oh you sound just like sid caesar whoa
you
wrote for sid caesar well i pitched him
a few times and then he murdered me
that checks out beware
[Music]
wow
you